Transcriptor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Gisela Giardino
Uno de mis alumnos, Alan,
vive en una casita de Villa Itatí
con su mamá, cinco hermanos,
su cuñada y un sobrinito.
Cuando termina de ayudar en la casa,
se arregla un poco y sale.
Atraviesa tres pasillos del barrio.
Sube una cuesta de barro muy empinada
y camina la cuadra que le falta
para llegar a la escuela.
No va a aprender con sus compañeros,
sino a hacer la fila para conseguir
la comida del día de su familia.
Por la cuarentena
el edificio está cerrado.
Mientras espera la vianda en la puerta,
aprovecha el wifi gratuito
para bajar las actividades
que sus profes le mandamos
y para enviar las que ya hizo.
Hoy le prestaron
el único celular de la familia
porque sabían que
iba a poder acceder a Internet.
Lee contento los mensajes
donde los profes lo alentamos
a seguir estudiando.
Y, además, respondemos sus preguntas.
No le resulta nada fácil
estudiar a distancia
pero, al menos, tiene un canal
donde hacer consultas.
Con las aulas vacías
se alejan las oportunidades
y se profundizan las desigualdades
que viven muchos chicos y chicas
hace tiempo.
Y hoy se las arreglan como pueden
para acceder a su derecho a aprender.
Sí es cierto que
las familias y los profes
recibimos a las escuelas
en nuestras casas
y les dimos el refugio que necesitan
para seguir funcionando.
Pero también es cierto que
se hizo más evidente que nunca
la necesidad de mantener
y potenciar los vínculos
que antes propiciaba el edificio escolar.
Es tan así que cuando los profes
nos encontramos en la escuela
para armar las bolsas de mercadería
lo más importante para nosotros
es tener noticias, intercambiar noticias,
de los chicos de los que
no sabemos nada últimamente.
Estamos tan alerta que,
mientras las bolsas se entregan,
recorremos la fila
buscando algún pariente
o cualquier otra persona
que pueda darnos alguna novedad.
Por la pandemia algunos chicos
fueron a vivir con otra familia
cuando sus padres, o sus abuelos
son internados, o aislados.
Si antes costaba un montón
que muchos de ellos
mantengan la regularidad
en la escuela secundaria,
ahora nuestra mayor preocupación
es que no abandonen,
que no abandonen el año.
Cuando la escuela se metió
en los hogares puso todo de cabeza.
Valen, por ejemplo,
ya está harto de tanta videollamada,
de tanta actividad
que le mandan sus profes,
tanto que le pidió a su mamá
"que se vaya la escuela de mi casa".
Madres y padres tuvimos
que alterar todas nuestras rutinas
para comprometernos todavía más
con la educación de nuestros hijos.
En mi caso fue bueno.
Mi hijo adolescente,
que tiene déficit de atención,
por primera vez en su escolaridad
lleva las tareas al día.
E, igual que Alan, consulta sus dudas
directamente con sus profesores.
Aprendió a manejar herramientas
para leer y escribir mejor.
A él y a muchos jóvenes,
el uso obligado de la tecnología
les ayudó a generar
una autonomía que no tenía.
Del otro lado del dispositivo
mis compañeros docentes
reaccionaron como pudieron.
La mayoría de nosotros
nos encargamos de nuestras familias
al mismo tiempo que
estamos trabajando en casa,
con recursos escasos,
atendiendo a los jóvenes
y a las familias a cualquier hora,
planificando permanentemente,
corrigiendo desde pantallas.
Daniel, por ejemplo,
es un profe excelente en el aula.
Pero se siente excluido por el poco
manejo que tiene de la tecnología
y la rapidez con la que
tuvo que aggiornarse.
En el otro extremo, Alejandra
se la pasa probando aplicaciones,
intentando una y mil veces por más
que esto le lleve horas y horas.
Y, también, como en cualquier empleo,
están quienes prefieren desentenderse
y nos sobrecargan de trabajo a los demás.
Así está la escuela hoy.
Como una máquina prácticamente desarmada.
Con todas sus piezas expuestas.
Se nos ven todas las hilachas.
Y un funcionamiento de emergencia
al que le pudimos dar con lo que teníamos.
Es una máquina antigua. Antigua y noble.
Pero que tiene un montón
de partes atadas con alambres
de reformas educativas
llegadas desde escritorios alejados
de la realidad de cada escuela.
Escuelas a las que, además de educar,
se le confiaron un montón
de responsabilidades enormes.
Y, como si esto fuera poco,
se las llenó de tareas inútiles
y tremendamente burocráticas.
Ahora tenemos una oportunidad única,
la de entre todos rearmarla
para que funcione mucho mejor.
Tenemos que dar más protagonismo
a los jóvenes
para que participen
y se comprometan con su educación.
Pero también para evitar
discusiones absurdas entre adultos,
que se resolverían fácilmente
con preguntarles.
Necesitamos mantener a las familias
dentro de esto.
Que se hicieron cargo
de la escuela en sus casas
y cuya participación activa
es importante no perder
en la escuela a la que volvamos.
Y, además, convocar a universidades,
profesorados, entidades sociales,
desde merenderos hasta clubes,
como parte del entramado social
que colabora
y se retroalimenta
de lo que pasa en la escuela.
Yo no sé cómo se va a ver esta máquina
que rearmemos con las piezas que teníamos
y las nuevas herramientas que tenemos.
Pero estoy segura
de que la presencialidad
tiene que tomar un rol súper importante
para construir mejores vínculos
y no para ser desperdiciada
en actividades que hoy
hemos entendido a la fuerza
que se pueden hacer a distancia,
o son obsoletas.
Si volvemos a la misma escuela
significa que no aprendimos nada.
Se lo debemos a las pibas, a los pibes,
a los profes, a las familias,
que están haciendo un esfuerzo enorme
por garantizar el derecho a la educación.
Una educación realmente de calidad,
que nos transforme
a todos desde los afectos,
desde lo personal y como ciudadanos.
Tenemos una oportunidad única
que no se va a volver a dar.
Ni en cien años.
El desafío es estar a la altura
y hacernos cargo de pensar y hacer
una mejor escuela entre todos.